日本語のネイティブじゃないからあなたが
酔っているから相手が酔っているから
おかずとご飯を一緒に食べていないからお
寺で1回しか礼をしなかったからねバラ州
に住んでいるからさっきまで知らない人と
Twitterで
ギアフェイスのことで揉めていたからだ
からナルトもドラゴンボールも
素晴らしいと言ってるよ
鬼と巨人はもちろんのことネイティブは他
の村の忍者を殺す日々を送ったりしてい
ないからだからナルトもいいアニメだって
お土産が買えたのにあなたはあえて買わ
なかったからはい警察本人見つけました
ネイティブじゃない俺を今見ているから
そしてこの
字幕を読んでいるから愛車がヒョンでだ
からダメでしょどう考えても残念ながら
それは日本語の教材動画にはならないから
っていうか一切当てにしない方がいいまだ
お箸の持ち方が間違ってるから違う親指は
こうで中指はその歌の歌詞の半分以上は不
自然な英語でできているからジャニーズは
青と抹茶フラペチーノの摂取率と
日本語能力の関係性がないのに等しいから
日本人の彼女か
UCバークレーに留学したからあの久美子
ゴミを出ても出してもらってるjlptの
受験は来年できるから昔々どこかのバカが
これを日本語のアールと名付けたから3回
も聞かなかったからガエル使えだからそれ
は自然な訳じゃなくて直訳だからあなたが
デスク周り紹介の動画をクリックする直前
だからカウボーイビバップの吹き替え版を
見たから
吹き替え版も素晴らしいのは知ってるそう
いう問題じゃない日本語の
皇帝アクセントを勉強したことがないから
[拍手]
完売の前にお酒をこっそり飲んだから見た
よ俺は
タンスの上のその刀は中国製だから
授業の会話相手の名前がとっととだから
ごめんね
久美子も言ってるけどマイペースすぎる
からまあなんといっても上手が褒め言葉だ
と思っているから